j'ai d'abord que il ya eu un déplacement
du président de la république à badens
yens toyota
oui c'est des sans emplois créés
investissement qui a dû être décidée à
mon avis hein
il ya déjà quelques quelques temps et
qui devait prendre en compte une
situation économique qui s'amélioraient
pour que toyota investissent à ce niveau
là donc l'attractivité
c'est un ensemble qui fait que
aujourd'hui il ya des investissements
que la croissance économique est là
alors après versailles pour la france
son image une habitation pdg du monde
entier pour pouvoir investir en france
bon c'est une opération de communication
très bien mais l'attractivité c'est
aussi l'ensemble des décisions qui sont
prises
moi je sais une brave honni c'est pas
bien c'est une manière toujours te faire
en sorte que notre pays soit un pays
dans lequel il y ait des investissements
et donc de l'emploi et donc de la
richesse
enfin c'est que vous faites pas un peu
la fine bouche vous dites c'est une
opération de communication il ya aussi
un élément nouveau peut-être c'est à cet
élément nouveau ça s'appelle confiance
pourquoi est-ce que ce qui ce qui
marchait pas ou qui marchait mal avant
tout d'un coup semble se débloquer c'est
une investissements et une raisons j'ai
fait qu'il me totalement contestée
c'est une question regardez il ya eu
près de 300000 emplois qui ont été créés
je crois en 2017
les investissements ont repris dès la
fin 2016
bon il ya une continuité et c'est tant
mieux la normale et en doutez travail
est une nouveauté la nouvelle république
une personne qui s'appelle emmanuel
macron mais j'ai bien vu j'ai accompli
chez colette et cosy impossibilité du
travail oui il ya une politique et de
l'aveu même du président de la
république emmanuel macron elle n'aura
d'effet que dans deux ans voilà donc si
il ya des gens qui viennent aujourd'hui
à ses yeux des partis qu'ils tirent
gloire aujourd'hui de résultats qui nous
ont mené cette loi il fait ce qu'il a à
faire pour appeler à des investissements
en france
mais je rappelle que sur la question
d'investissement il est reparti avant et
l'année 2007 a été une année justement
qui marque 2010n vraie tendance à tuer
avec une investissement extrêmement
forts qui avait commencé je ne m'appelle
je les dis à la fin de l'année 2016 un
peu tard par rapport au quinquennat de
françois hollande
mais cette reprise
là et cette consolidation économique
elle est là